economía en directo América de Francia
24 y está ya con nosotros en el estudio
nuevamente Juan Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo
para empezar hablando de Francia porque
hoy la primera ministra de ese país será
los detalles y la polémica reforma de
pensiones Así es Raúl y con la reforma
solo pasará una cosa Esto es claro los
franceses tendrán que trabajar más
tiempo para jubilarse Y es que según la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económicos Francia tiene una
de las edades de jubilación más bajas
del mundo industrializado y gasta más
que la mayoría de los demás países con
pensiones con casi el 14% de la
producción económica vamos ahora a las
cifras según una encuesta de la app una
empresa de investigación y consultoría
del país galo solo el 27% de las
personas encuestadas están de acuerdo
con aumentar la edad de jubilación de
ese 27% el 9% está de acuerdo con que se
aumente hasta los 65 años y el 18 hasta
los 64 años un 47% no quiere cambios en
y la edad de jubilación y un 25% quiere
que la jubilación sea más temprana que
incluso la que se encuentra actualmente
Pero qué dicen los políticos de cada
lado escuchemos
se ha Atrapado en un monólogo social no
ha escuchado a nadie en absoluto y está
listo para avanzar con fuerza pisoteando
el punto de vista de la mayoría de los
franceses porque como mostró ayer una
encuesta de opinión el 85% de los
franceses se oponen a cualquier
extensión de la edad de jubilación y los
entendemos porque es insoportable
trabajar más tiempo
Tenemos una gran determinación para
hacer esta reforma lo que está en juego
aquí es explicar por qué necesitamos
esta reforma con 25 años de déficit
importante del sistema de pensiones por
delante Juan Pablo cambiemos de
información vamos a hablar ahora sobre
la Cumbre de líderes de América del
Norte y cuáles son los temas que se van
a tratar a nivel económico Raúl pues uno
de los temas que se espera que se a
nivel económico es la inversión en
materia de semiconductores en el estado
de Arizona teniendo en cuenta la
vinculación entre ambos países sin
embargo lo que más inquieta a Estados
Unidos y Canadá es la decisión de México
de limitar la participación de las
compañías extranjeras en el mercado
minero de ese país previamente la
ministra de comercio internacional de
Canadá expresó su preocupación por el
tratamiento de las empresas mineras
canadienses en México y la necesidad de
procesos transparentes para los permisos
del sector de la minería el presidente
de México hizo un reclamo a homólogo de
Estados Unidos por lo que calificó como
un olvido hacia América Latina y biden
por su parte dijo que sus compromisos
como principal Economía del mundo
también están en Europa en África y el
resto del mundo escuchemos
determinar
con ese olvido ese abandono ese desdén
hacia América Latina y el Caribe
opuesto a la política
de La buena vecindad
de ese titán de la libertad que fue el
presidente Franklin de lado rooseveltt
en los últimos 15 años hemos gastado
miles de millones de dólares en el
hemisferio y lo que tenemos que hacer es
lo que ustedes han hecho y les digo
felicitaciones debemos seguir apoyando y
construyendo democracias e instituciones
del hemisferio Juan Pablo cambiamos
nuevamente información porque este
pasado domingo china relajó
drásticamente sus medidas restrictivas y
estrictas de la política de cero covid
esto por supuesto va a traer
repercusiones económicas pero positivas
y negativas que se sabe hasta el momento
Pues luego de tres años de la estricta
política de cero covid se espera que la
reactivación económica en China pueda
mostrar resultados positivos por lo
menos en este primer trimestre evitando
al mismo tiempo que esa activación
presione la inflación que es
precisamente lo que pasó en el resto del
mundo cuando se tuvo esa apertura
después de la pandemia efecto rebote Lo
cierto es que la ola de contagios de
covid trajo estrictos controles y duros
impuestos para por países vecinos como
Corea del Sur y Japón esto enojó a
Beijing y este lunes el gobierno chino
anunció que no considerará visados de
corta duración incluyendo aquellos
destinados al turismo la actividad
económica o los viajes y motivos de
médicos para los surcoreanos también
congeló los visados para los japoneses
indicadores económicos Juan Pablo
seguimos hablando de Asia porque las
bolsas cerraron en terreno mixto luego
de las tensiones entre los países
vecinos de China tras la reapertura el
sector del turismo se empieza a activar
y los inversores se han visto optimistas
con el final de la política de cero
covid las bolsas en Europa siguen
operando mayoritariamente en pérdida muy
atentos a cómo reaccionen los sindicatos
de la Reforma pensional de Manuel macron
Juan Pablo gracias entonces por toda la
información económica y nosotros pasamos
a saludar a Cabrera que tiene toda la
información me parece
[Música]